the dark wizard King has returned and we
just witnessed one of the best moments
in the history of Black Clover this
chapter changes everything the character
development was absolutely beautiful the
ending of this chapter may be the best
chapter ending in the entire Series so
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy my Black Clover
content and you want me to keep making
more leave a quick like and comment
right now to help me out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you happen to
be one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos but aren't subscribed
yet do me a huge favor and click that
subscribe button right now we are trying
to hit 2 million subscribers here on the
channel That would be insane finally
this video will of course contain Black
Clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned so as
we saw in the last chapter once the
black Bulls confronted Paladin damnatio
they took extreme risks and made Extreme
sacrifices just to buy the witches and
funeral enough time to finish the ritual
and bring us step back from Hino country
many of the black Bulls were seriously
injured and gray and gauche were
horribly wounded their wounds are
definitely bad enough to be called fatal
under normal circumstances but this is a
Shonen with magic so we can't jump to
conclusions at the end of the chapter
socray was able to seal gray and
gaucha's injuries in order to prevent
them from dying and then those black
Bulls who were still standing continued
their punishing fight against damn natio
the latest chapter begins with sakrei
explaining that her ceiling magic was
able to seal the wounds and pain that
gray and gosh have suffered up to this
point but if socrate takes too much
damage during the battle her magic will
be undone and gray and gauche will die I
have to say that as tragic as the panel
of the two of them looks it's also
eerily romantic as it is clear that
gauche sacrificed his life to protect
gray and we see that gray is reaching
out towards gauche lovingly even as she
appears to be on the branch think of
death nevertheless this chapter
establishes that thanks to such craze
ceiling magic gray and gauche are not
technically dead so there is still hope
for them meanwhile the remaining black
Bulls are still going all out against
damnatio and we see that Charmy is using
her food magic to manifest that giant
wolf that consumes the magic of others
and she is using this giant wolf to
fight damnatio everyone really is doing
their very best under these difficult
circumstances and we see that some of
the guardian angels have been
successfully damaged and destroyed by
the black bulls that in itself is no
easy feat but of course that's still not
enough to defeat damnnatio that said the
nation is somewhat concerned the black
Bulls are managing to destroy his angels
and they are even able to reach him
directly and attack him overall they are
being effective in their mission they
are definitely buying more time for Asta
to arrive even though this comes at a
great cost to their own bodies damnatio
feels that he has no other choice but to
activate his secret weapon a final
deadly trick that he has up his sleeve
suddenly we see Charming in her adult
form being slashed by what looks like a
thousand little cuts and this takes her
completely by surprise Zora suffers a
similar fate just as he is about to
reach damnatio and he is suddenly unable
to make contact with him damnnatio then
reveals the Dark Truth some of the
paladins were given a second magic
attribute by Lucius and he himself was
granted the power of the Supreme ranked
devil ball this supreme devil was
purified by Lucius and then his power
was bestowed upon thematio kind of like
the power of Beelzebub was bestowed upon
Paladin Lily ball possesses atmosphere
magic and this magic appears to create
an invisible barrier around amnesio that
destroys everything that comes close to
it the Amnesia is trying to pull a
satoru Gojo over here by making it
virtually impossible to make contact
with him and good luck defeating someone
you can't even land a single hit on say
what you will about Lucius but he
definitely didn't underestimate Asta and
the black Bulls although he couldn't
come to stop the ritual himself he
definitely made sure that Paladin
damnatio would be as overpowered as
possible for this fight in this moment
of desperation for the black Bulls we
are given some insight into secrae's
State of Mind at this time and although
you might be thinking man I don't really
care about the craze inner monologue I
just want to see the fight trust me this
is worth it socray's perspective here
sets up one of the best moments in Black
Clover in my humble opinion due to the
fact that she spent 500 years as the
bird nettle socray had largely lost
touch with her Humanity in particular
she stopped having any lingering
attachments to the world and everyone in
it back before she became Nero her
entire life revolved around Lumiere and
once Lumiere was sealed away her her
life's sole purpose was waiting for the
moment that he would be on seal so she
didn't want to be attached to the world
in any way she didn't want friends or
family or any such thing because her job
was to wait for hundreds of years all
the people she might have gotten
attached to in the meantime would have
gotten old and died anyway so what was
the point of getting close to anyone but
then when Lumiere was finally unsealed
he told secrete that now was the time
for her to win new happiness for herself
and to make new friends in this era that
is exactly what she found with the black
Bulls new friends that she became close
to New happiness and new deep and
personal attachments she fully regained
her humanity and her heart expanded and
became a truly human heart once again so
now as Sacre watches her new friends her
new family being viciously attacked and
brutally injured by damnnatio she just
can't take it anymore she begs for it
all to stop she can't bear the thought
of losing her new friends and her new
life as the amnesio finally breaks into
the place where the ritual is taking
place things look really bad Vanessa and
the other witches can't keep focusing on
the ritual because the enemy is right
there and attacking them so the ritual
is over
socray is injured and lying on the floor
she is watching all of this happening
she is witnessing the impending death of
all her friends and loved ones in an act
of pure desperation she calls out to
Asta she says that the reason she's
alive the reason she has friends now the
reason she got her heart back it's all
because of our stuff socray screams out
for us to come back already I can't keep
going on without you she says and you
can truly see the pain and Desperation
in her face as we know sakrei is very
rarely emotional so it is truly
heartbreaking to see her so intensely
emotional in this moment as expected
sucree's cries have no effect on
damnation and he prepares to end at all
right here and now but then socray feels
a hand touched the top of her head and
suddenly she realizes that none other
than our boy Asta is standing just above
her Asta doesn't pause to speak to
anyone directly his face is Stern and
determined his eyes are firmly fixed on
damnation and as he finally steps
forward to face the Paladin Socrates
sees just how much Asta resembles
Lumiere Asta is without a doubt wizard
King material Asta thanks everyone for
buying him the time he needed and as the
long-awaited battle between Asta and
amnesio is about to commence this epic
chapter comes to an end okay I freaking
loved this moment with socray and Asta
not only did it give us so much
character depth and development for
sakrei but Asta placing his hand on her
head in that moment of desperation gave
me the same Vibes as the Nami and Luffy
scene in our Long Park the moment when
Luffy places his Straw Hat upon nami's
head that is the moment I knew that one
piece would be an absolutely legendary
series and for me to say that a scene in
another other manga reminded me of that
moment is the highest praise I can give
to Black Clover I was wondering how
Tabata would bring Asta back and after
all that anticipation I was wondering
how lost his return could possibly live
up to all the hype honestly I have to
say kudos to Tabata because he did it
this was truly awesome emotional and
Incredibly satisfying did you guys like
asa's return as much as I did let me
know in the comments but okay what
happens now Asta is obviously gonna
fight the Amnesia and since most of the
black Bulls are already injured we can
expect this to be a pretty much
one-on-one fight with anti-magic on his
side and all the new skills he learned
in Hino country austa is of course the
heavy favorite but we do have to talk
about the ball we know he's not one of
the three strongest Devils but he is a
supreme rank or highest ranked devil so
we can't underestimate him in the demon
lore of our own world the demon bile or
ball is a demonic King who who has the
power of invisibility including the
ability to make others invisible in some
versions of the story he is also a
shapeshifter and he has the ability to
make himself popular with the people
depending on the version he is also
sometimes referred to as a subordinate
of either asteroth or lucifugus the part
about invisibility has already been
established since the Amnesia can use
Ball's power to create deadly invisible
barriers
but I wonder what other powers ball will
allow damnatio to use will he be able to
make himself invisible will he be able
to shapeshift will he be able to
brainwash austa's allies with his powers
of popularity to switch sides and fight
against Austin instead I can't wait to
see what other powers this supreme devil
has in his Arsenal and definitely let me
know what powers you guys think he has
down in the comments below finally this
chapter made it very clear that Asta is
Wizard King material socray sees him as
someone who clearly embodies the essence
of the first wizard King Lumiere and the
way that Asta showed up and comforted
sacrae in her moment of need definitely
screams next wizard King to me so what
do you guys think was this Tabata
foreshadowing that Asta will in fact
become the next wizard King will the
Clover kingdom ever accept a dark wizard
King who has the power of a devil on his
side
don't forget to leave your feedback
below if you enjoyed this black lower
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you're new to the channel or you're
one of the over 50 of people who watch
my videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet please do me a huge favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free but it helps me out a lot you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys